indeed leading the grand chess tour is
wesley's soul wesley
were you concerned by the speed with
which he was moving initially and this
line did it come as a surprise to you at
all yeah that's true i didn't expect he
won today i think maximus played a few
lines generally he sticks to
to his lines he's very principled uh he
doesn't but today i'm surprised he
played rook e1 uh i thought he would go
for the end game or some d3 stuff
um so so yeah it's surprising but i uh
actually didn't analyze this d4
like knight fit three
this was the ending that you had
prepared probably all day and all night
not not all day but
all night
okay but yeah also like max famous very
principal they could also play bishop c4
and move through the piano yes and also
it's very complex i thought that's what
he would go for
but i didn't look at this d4 for a long
time v5 be i think i'm supposed to play
bishop e6 and knight d6
i think it's slightly more accurate that
way white cannot play this queen after
idea because here he has queen f3
and black is slightly worse but
fortunately it's very solid i can't
remember any analysis here
i me i'm not sure if i could take him on
d4 but here
which movement
like here like computer would give a
more accurate move yeah
like they say bishop e6 is dubious but
maybe this rook a v1
and it's very dangerous
this was not very bad this is really the
computer the computer yeah well so why
did why did the computer get bishop e6
as dubious data five here was the
computer's top choice ah bishop f8
knight before yeah dennis borros
mentioned queen app sixth year after the
game yes
but
but like i don't remember anything okay
gf6 that looks okay for black but with
the engine
bishop e7 maybe it's supposed to still
be okay just crazy
yeah the engine just gives crazy lines
so it's like
20 years ago no one would ever play like
this with white
but now the computer gives heroes then
it's definitely playable
so that's why
i decided to play bishop e6
and just a slightly worse position but
fortunately it held like here
i like knight e8 take stakes and then i
reroute my knight to the g7
um
and
here maxim can find a way to break
through
uh rook a8 yeah and i think this is very
accurate what i did queen m6 queen d8
yeah and once the queens are traded
black is fine the point is that after f4
uh
but leads nowhere after bishop d7
f5 f6
rook e7 g5
so after that queens were traded i think
black's position is very safe but
obviously the opening didn't go
the best for me but it's sufficient to
hold fortunately
you are clearly leading the tour and
a lot of things have to shake out to
have you not win the tour
however you're half a point behind in
the sink field cup itself yeah and of
course winning a second sing field cup
would be fantastic what are what are
your thoughts about your game with
lanier tomorrow you have the white
pieces
yeah the
yeah it'll be funny maxine wins then it
was the first time someone won the thing
that got twice
but uh no the
you mean clear by themselves yes that
would be true why who won the thing
philippe coughlin's five magnus fabian
lavon tied one year ah and they've all
won another year oh yeah yeah yeah right
i forgot about that
first
you forgot about those guys yeah yeah
yeah those are there are three winners
forget about those guys
oh yeah you're right they tied for first
yeah there wasn't a playoff held
just like this one could be a tie as
well
and there won't be any playoffs for the
sing-fil cup title
yeah yeah that's true the thing is i
haven't been playing well the last few
days uh it seems like every single year
i start the grand chester very strongly
like in europe
like previous years i would do very well
in belgium paris
and then it seems like in saint louis i
would limp my way to the finish line
like if you check that yesterday happens
every single year i would be leading or
top two in granchester and after things
world cup i'd finish fourth
uh so i'm happy to draw the game today
uh
i think uh my plane last few days has
been quite unfortunate yesterday i had
real chances to win the peter was game
plus two at some point so yesterday was
really my chance to to win but not not
winning that game felt first very hard
on me
uh i
yeah i just wanna play some good chess
but it seems like
always in the same field cup i'm limping
towards the finish line and i really
want to change that
you still didn't answer the question
about you versus lanier yeah yeah well
uh
all depends also whether him or fabi
wins today if they do they reach plus
three
obviously magic number is plus three and
the white pieces so i guess i have to to
give my best
yeah i hope to to play well tomorrow
but but uh
but yeah we'll see i think yesterday was
really my moment i missed it but
i don't know we'll see what happens all
right well good luck in the last game oh
yeah it seems like you want me to
predict
you're gonna pull something out of it
yeah yeah yeah that's true uh linear is
very solid with black uh let's see if he
plays usual
wesley does it uh sorry just last quick
question i'll let you go and prepare for
your last round game does it affect you
your individual score
versus mvl as we we did a head to head
yeah and we were rather surprised that
he's taken you down what's the score
four four zero with 16 cross with a lot
a lot a lot of draws but you never
does that go through your head uh for a
big game like today's game yeah maxim
it's no secret maximum has always been
my kryptonite i think partly the reason
is because he plays very dynamic
openings with black he plays the
nightdorf and the gruntfield openings
which i tend to be uncomfortable against
and he knows them very well
and
with white he plays for principal this
e4 somehow his style is just very
unpleasant for me so it's it's no secret
uh so i really want to to beat him once
exactly
all right well thank you very much and
good luck for the last round tomorrow
wesley
big big big result i got it